on vous remercie pour votre question je
vous assurer tout de suite qu'elle que
ma réponse n'a pas été préparée à l'aide
de l'intelligence artificielle est
réaffirmée que nous avons l'ardente
obligation de faire en sorte de voir se
développer en France et en Europe dans
les prochains mois des modèles
d'intelligence artificielle générative
d'abord parce que nous en avons les
moyens de Blaise Pascal dont nous fêtons
cette année le 400e anniversaire de la
naissance à Hugo du mini le copain
lauréat de la médaille field en
mathématiques l'année dernière la 12ème
pour la France notre pays n'a jamais
cessé d'être une grande nation de
mathématiques et puis ensuite parce que
nous en avons besoin vous l'avez dit il
est hors de question que cette
technologie se retrouve entre les mains
de puissants intérêts privés qui
placeraient l'Europe dans une situation
de dépendance et par ailleurs nous
voulons mettre entre les mains de nos
concitoyens des outils qui soient forgés
au feu de la langue et de la culture
française alors nous n'avons pas attendu
tchat Jipi pour agir il y a 5 ans à la
suite du rapport vinani le président de
la République a souhaité bâtir une
stratégie nationale pour l'intelligence
artificielle dotée de 1 milliard et demi
d'euros 5 ans plus tard quatre centres
d'excellence ont été créés dont l'un
dans votre département à Nice à Toulouse
mais également à Grenoble à Nice et à
Paris nous avons doublé le nombre de
diplômés dans la discipline nous avons
aujourd'hui 600 startups qui sont
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle et cette stratégie
nationale est prolongée dans le cadre de
France 2030 avec un milliard deux
d'euros supplémentaires qui vont être
enrichies pour tenir compte de l'arrivée
de l'intelligence artificielle
générative par un volet dédié que le
Président de la République annoncera la
semaine prochaine sans doute à
l'occasion de vivatech s'agissant de la
de la régulation puisque vous l'avez
abordé également avec la première
ministre avec le ministre de l'économie
et des finances nous veillons à ce qu'un
juste équilibre soit trouvé entre la
protection des citoyens et
l'encouragement à l'innovation le
rapport de votre collègue Philippe
Pradal sur le sujet éclairera les
décisions que nous aurons à prendre je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup